all right people
i'm starting a minute early that's right
i'm cutting off
kamala harris which means i'm going to
get a very condescending look an evil
cackle
and some sort of very smug comment about
cutting her off
nobody cuts off kamala harris nobody
puts
baby in a corner ugh all right
i watched did you watch uh
pretty much my predictions from this
morning all came true
uh what i said was basically that mike
pence
just has to make sure he doesn't fall
out of his seat and he was gonna win
so uh that's all he did and
and in effect he won um kamala harris oh
wait a minute before i go too deep
i'm doing this with whiskey i hope
you're doing it with a drink of choice
i do have the stormtrooper ice cube once
again
people were really into the stormtrooper
ice cube i can't really explain it's a
mold
like people were saying how do you make
a stormtrooper ice cube
it's hard to explain how it actually
works it's kind of rubber and it's sort
of like you gotta like push it out with
your thumb it's a it's a real situation
but anyway uh here take a drink with me
because god knows if you watch that
thing
you deserve it my god
it's a little johnny walker black label
by the way people are asking what kind
of whiskey i was drinking
um all right i'm gonna try to plow
through that thing we'll do about a half
hour here
then i'm jumping on with the fine folks
at the blaze in a little bit um but my
predictions this morning basically
were were right and and not that
surprising pence just
had to not fall out of his chair he just
had to seem
uh presidential vice presidential he had
to basically know what he's talking
about he basically had to show
that if something happened that he could
steer the ship
and that for anyone that is nervous
about trump's temperament
or the way he tweets or coronavirus or
the fact that he's 74 and overweight and
whatever
that if pence had to be president in
effect he could do it i think it's
fairly obvious
that he can um i'll get to the issues in
a minute i'm going to do the broad stuff
first so it's pretty obvious that he can
right um of course the entire debate
probably was
sidetracked by the minute and a half
where uh fly was on his hair
towards the end i'm sure many of you saw
that and for after about a minute it
started appearing to be a dead fly
uh but it actually was a living fly and
it did fly off
his head which you know and i say this
with all due respect you know
pence he's got obviously got a lot of
spray in that hair it's not the most
exciting haircut
it's right it's a very it's a very you
know i'm mike pence haircut
uh but you're putting a lot of spray in
that thing for one of these things and
i'm not
a guy that's going to sit here and
pretend there's no hairspray in here
okay i got
there's a lot i could lose my hand if i
touch this thing that's it i'd do the
rest of the thing like this
but i really thought that the fly was
actually just going to be stuck
in the hairspray so thankfully the fly
did fly away so that that could have
been a disaster of course what's really
unfortunate about the fly incident is
that's going to overshadow
what was happening at that moment where
they started getting into some
interesting stuff
about race and obviously there's uh
there's a whole bunch of contention over
there
that's where um kamala then repeated the
lie
the absolute lie it is a lie
people this very fine people thing that
they keep saying trump said
after charlottesville and he did say
they were very fine people
right after saying that he absolutely
condemns
the white nationalists and the neo-nazis
he was saying there's very
fine people on both sides meaning you
take them out and condemn them
but the the argument of whether
monuments and statues should stand in
this case they were talking about robert
e lee that there are fine people on both
sides and of course
that is the truth now the media please
people
find me someone at cnn hey jake tapper
this one goes out to you
because you're the only one there with
even the slightest shred of dignity at
this point
uh why am i i'm not a journalist i am
some guy
with some whiskey sitting in my office
and for some reason
i have to tell more truth than you
people are able to you've destroyed your
entire
industry by your lies and your lies of
omission
so jake tapper if you're watching this
or wolf blitzer
or don lemon or any of you people
chris cuomo you angry steroided freak
if could could any of you please just
play the freaking clip and just
debunk the lie because actually what
you're doing is not only are you tearing
down your own industry of journalism
you're actually helping getting trump
elected because the more and more people
that see that the
very the very premise of the biden
campaign according to joe biden the
night he decided to get involved in the
campaign
was during charlottesville because
donald trump
uh you know he said the thing about very
fine people and that's when biden
decided to get involved
it's a lie so the the premise of the
campaign is a lie
they all know it's a lie what that woman
susan page who's
the the moderator tonight who by the way
is in the midst of writing
a biography on uh nancy pelosi so you
wonder what what uh
side of the aisle is she on right and
then by the way the next moderator
at the next presidential debate is a
former biden intern i mean you can't
make this crap
up it's all fixed you get it
you're destroying your own industry
journalists and the more that you
destroy it not only are you destroying
ultimately your livelihood because
you're all going to lose your jobs
because no one's going to watch
everyone's going to tune out of your
nonsensical [ __ ]
but but even bigger than that you're
getting donald trump elected because the
average person is
finally for at least as long as the rest
of us can be on twitter and everywhere
else
the average person is able to see the
truth so kamala knows so really
i want to focus on this because think
about this kamala knows and joe biden
knows
that they can go up there and they can
flat out
lie about something massive this isn't a
lie about oh tax cuts this and kamala
lied about the 400 000 and the tax cuts
and whatever and
you can say and and she also lied about
the fracking i mean there's a million
videos abide in saying no new fracking
we're getting rid of fracking we're
getting rid of fossil fuels okay forget
those lies
there's something about this particular
lie because it's about
race that that seems particularly
pernicious it seems particularly
invasive into the system
and why won't anyone track it why won't
anyone dare
tell the truth and i think you know the
answer because these people are not
journalists
they're activists and in most cases
they're democratic activists
but think of the balls think of the
balls it takes for biden to go up there
and lie
right and then for kamala to go up there
and lie and susan page
do you not know it's a lie like do you
not know and if you do not know you
are not qualified to moderate a debate
oh you people you could really drive
someone to drink you know that
awful humans it's really
it's just it's just incredibly annoying
all right um
there was an interesting clip right up
front where
uh they're both the question in effect
was
uh pence you know your guy is fat in 74
and had corona
and uh you know uh kamala your guy's
77 will be 78 by january
and she didn't say dementia but like we
all know that's like the subtext of the
thing and
pence just refused to answer the
question which at that point was fine
because kamala had
had been running all over him um but
okay so let's just
let me back up for a second i'm getting
a little ahead of myself the basic if
you want to do the who won
thing pence one period that i don't
think that's a partisan thing
um i think even for someone like me that
i as i always describe myself as
begrudgingly
pro-choice um and the abortion thing is
so difficult to talk about and no one's
really honest and you know the right
makes it seems like the left
hates babies and the left makes it seem
like the right hates women and these are
nonsensical way of looking at these
things
but i actually thought that pence's
answer when he basically like flat
out you know said you know i'm very
proud to be pro-life
that's a slight um you know slight
deviation of what he actually said
i actually thought the candor and
clarity of it was kind of nice
politicians don't
clearly say what they were whatever
they're going to say for example when
kamala
was talking about packing the courts so
why don't why don't we jump
to that one this is clip three this is
kamala uh
well this is actually pence calling out
kamala uh on whether she would pack the
courts
i think the american people really
deserve an answer senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett is
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules you're going to change the rules
now you've refused to answer the
question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the mr
vice president
speaking i'm speaking okay
in 1864 one of the
i think political heroes certainly of
the president i i assume if you
also mr vice president is abraham
yeah i think we got our answer there
obviously they're going to do everything
they can to pack the courts
they're already talking about changing
the electoral college they want
to there is no norm that we have
that these people won't want to change
that is not being alarmist and crazy
this is what
the base wants and and what is driving
this
is that what sits underneath what seems
perhaps like a moderate biden harris
ticket
is a crazed radical base that does not
like america period thus
is the irony of the biden campaign you
know
uh kamala the whole the whole democratic
side of this thing at the moment
basically is saying america is evil
america is racist we're systemically
racist we're awful
capitalism is terrible and also
the guy who's going to fix it has been
around for
47 years doing this stuff he was busy
you know he had stuff to do smelling
little girl's hair
things like that now he's going to get
to it he's going to get to the hard work
and of course it's just
nonsense so it's like the very premise
it's not just that they launched the
campaign on a lie the the very fine
people
but the idea that these are the people
uh that are gonna fix this thing it's
just such
absolute nonsense so um of course
they're gonna pack the courts
they're lying she's lying they're
intentionally being dishonest
biden's answer on it was also ridiculous
because he basically was like i can't
comment on it because
uh we're in the middle of an election
i'm pretty sure that's when you're
supposed to comment on what your
opinions are as to when you're gonna
potentially be
president i think that's what this whole
thing's about good lord
um but okay so so let's back up for a
second
you got pence and he's there and you
know basically
sure he had the fly in the hair also
he's got something going on with his uh
i think it's his left eye
a little bloodshot or something i don't
know what was going on there but
basically
he sat in the chair i think he was
presidential he wasn't rude
by the way we had one of my guys while
we were watching timing because
susan page kept saying two minutes two
minutes uninterrupted two minutes
uninterrupted
several times at least five times pence
was interrupted by susan page before two
minutes
and kamala was not interrupted after two
minutes you can check i mean we had an
iphone with a clock
we started checking it so that that's
just that just is what it is i'm just
putting it out there
so anyway pence i thought issues aside
for a moment
i thought he did a perfectly fine job
which was all that he had to do
he just sort of had to sit there and say
i can kind of stabilize this thing
that's what i've been here for
and and he offered trump actually a lot
of nice praise and i think there were
moments
where maybe he didn't even have to go
that far but he did
kamala man this is a deeply
deeply unlikable person i mean her
hurt the smiles and the fake laughs
and i'm talking i'm talking you're
interrupting me
like she's just awful like who would
want to be around a person like that
she's not
you can tell she's just like a power
hungry maniac
and the and the clip that i keep talking
about from the from the debates
this this thing where they were asking
biden about executive actions on guns
and he says it has to be constitutional
and she laughs in his face and says
joe can't we say yes we can it's like
she's telling you who she is
she wants to use the office of the
presidency to
to take away one of your fundamental
rights right the right to bear arms or
at least
significantly alter it she laughed in
biden's face
when he said we'd have to do something
constitutional
i know call me old school i believe in
the constitution i know i believe in the
bill of rights
free speech you know freedom of assembly
that sort of old school
that that white supremacist stuff you
know so i i just
i can't imagine anybody i'm trying guys
i'm really trying to be
to be impartial like obviously i have my
opinions on this
obviously right like it just goes
without saying um
but i can't imagine anyone watching that
and thinking boy that kamala harris
seems like a nice person
that seems like the type of person i'd
like to have over for dinner
her smugness and and that condescending
attitude and it's like the way she would
turn and be so dismissive to pence
where it's like he didn't do that at all
you know like he didn't do it at all the
the asymmetry there i just think was
obvious let's show a clip actually
of one of the times when she barked back
at him this is clip two let's throw to
that
president wanted people to remain calm
well let's go i don't know but susan i
this is important and i want to add but
if mr vice president i'm speaking
uh i'm speaking yeah you can have 15
and then we'll give the vice president
so i want to ask the american people
how calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
man i do not like her i do not like her
and let me be very clear
let me be very clear for the uh twitter
trolls and the loser youtubers who clip
everything i say and remove words
and then try to make things out to be
not what they are
it has nothing to do with her being a
woman it has nothing to do with her
being black
there's also this question a lot of
people are saying she's not even black
because i guess her father is
indian and her mother is jamaican and a
lot of jamaicans don't consider some
themselves black per se they just
consider themselves jamaican
okay i'm not even going to get into the
minutia of that
but this has nothing to do with the
complexion of her skin
or her boobs or anything else she's just
deeply unlikable she comes off as
extremely entitled
try to imagine a man behaving that way
how would you feel about it
pretty much the same way and that's
that's the point
so so look if we're choosing winners and
losers here
as i said with the with the regular
debate the the presidential debate
winners and losers it's like okay it's
whatever that middle group is that
undecided group of people
and did you move anyone anyway well the
vp debates i don't think there's any
numbers
on this really i'd love to see some
stats on this in the history
of presidential elections has has the vp
choice ever made a real
movement one way or another and i don't
know that there's
any any evidence of that lost my lost my
cap of my pen there
um i i don't i just don't know that
there's any evidence of that
um you may remember there are times when
it's like
very clear that one vice presidential
candidate has
demolished another one this will be a
little bit of an older reference for you
youtube kids out there
but uh back in in 88 i was 12 years old
and i was just getting into politics and
and what got me into politics actually
was i was in seventh or eighth grade
and i think was eighth grade and we were
doing a mock election and i was on the
campaign
staff for michael dukakis he was the
democrat he was the liberal he was the
lefty
and he was running against george h.w
bush
and he was you know this is after reagan
and he's a conservative
and he likes war and money and hates
poor people
blah blah blah and uh dukakis's
vp was a guy by the name of lloyd benson
who was
an older guy although by these standards
now old old is the new young i suppose
uh but he had lloyd benson as his vp and
of course george h.w
bush had uh dan quayle and
um most of you remember dan quayle
probably because he was sort of just
like the brunt of every joke but he was
just like some kind of like
idiot basically um and there was a line
in the debate where dan quayle said
something about
jack kennedy and lloyd benson looked at
him and turned and said
i knew jack kennedy and you sir are no
jack kennedy
you know everyone went crazy with it and
my
point of all this is that lloyd benson
in effect demolished
dan quayle in that debate nobody debated
that
it was just known to everybody and
dukakis still lost
the election so the vp debate doesn't
really move one way or another
but as i said this morning it is a
little bit different these days
because of the age of both of the
candidates and and even though trump you
know went in on
what was it friday or thursday evening
for corona and he was out by
by sunday night or whatever it's like or
monday morning whatever it is
um look the guy had corona he's 74 he's
a lot of
like overweight joe biden 77 and and
probably has dementia so like
there is a little bit more to think
about with the vps
uh this time around than before and
that's why it was actually kind of funny
that neither one of them answered that
question
right up front as for the rest of the
the fireworks i mean look
the race stuff either you see it or you
don't
at this point like either you see the
lives of the media
and how they're trying to constantly
tell you that these protests
are peaceful and all of these things
even as we watch
stores get burned down and people be
assaulted and people that are trying to
eat at restaurants be attacked and cars
be stopped in streets we're supposed to
not see what we see so
if you were just a mainstream media
viewer
i suppose you would think that these are
mostly peaceful things or that somehow
the evil right with the white
supremacists are burning these things
down
i don't know what you'd think at this
point i i can't even imagine where your
brain is at actually
at this point if you think that the the
threat of violence on the streets
right now is is coming from the right
wing
okay it's coming from antifa it's coming
from black lives matter we know it it's
more and more and more and more
um you know i mentioned like two weeks
ago
that in west hollywood where i used to
live which is the gayest place on earth
they got a
they got rainbow crosswalks it's gayer
than oz okay this is a pretty freaking
gay place
um you would think that it would be a
land of bastion of
of tolerance and diversity and peace
well it looks like a war zone over there
because everything's boarded up and has
been boarded up for a long time now
and they have signs that say black lives
matter on them and we
are for tolerance and other meaningless
slogans hashtag that
and the reason they have it is not
because they believe these are peaceful
movements it's because they don't want
their buildings destroyed
it's a mafia racket people that's what
it is but but i think the race
conversation has devolved into such a
stupid thing that we're we're talking
about
two totally different things and and i
think you know my feelings on this
all a society can do all a just society
can do it can't promise that we're going
to have
equity of outcomes that everybody
regardless of their race and gender and
sexuality and everything else
will be equal on the other side meaning
they will have made the same thing as
their life
as somebody else right like life takes
hard work
like life takes a little bit of luck
life takes networking
life takes making connections life takes
all of the things like all life takes
getting a good education life takes
coming from a good family all of those
things that
is what hopefully you can piece together
some
thing right you can piece together some
sort of coherent
ball that you can hold as you go ahead
in life and and maybe make something
successful of yourself
and that's regardless or irregardless as
they say
online uh of your skin color erase or
anything else
the idea that the system can come in and
say ah
okay you're this color you should get
more
stuff as i always say it kind of sounds
right and then you have to think about
it and then go
well wait a minute that means we have to
punish somebody else
and you know i'm a man of my word
because we hired somebody this week and
i'm not going to tell you
their age or their sexuality or their
gender or whether they had a limp or a
lazy eye
but i assure you none of those factors
came into play
it was about can they do the job
and as i said in the direct message this
morning it's like in the old days
if you ignored um
gender and sexuality and all those
things then then that was good right
that was good
if you just ignored it and now if you
ignored it somehow that is bigotry
that's how
backwards this idiotic set of ideas that
we're being
inundated with is whiskey time
there's something about whiskey for a
debate that seems right to me as you
guys know i'm more of a red wine guy
usually
but there's something about whiskey
while watching politics
and then oh is this what happens you
start drinking whiskey and watching
politics next thing you're smoking a
cigar
you're sitting on a leather chair in
front of a fireplace i don't know if i
want to fully go that route but i could
see why something happens there i'm not
exactly sure what that is
but i can see why something happens
let's do i think we have one other clip
here oh this was
uh let's go to clip one for a sec uh
this was uh kamala blaming trump on
uh some of the corona stuff so let's
throw to that whatever the vice
president is claiming the administration
has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over 210 000
dead bodies in our country american
lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
and you know the vice president is the
head of the task force and
knew on january 28th how serious this
was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned
that they knew about it and then when
that was exposed
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go but susan
this is important and i want to add mr
vice president i'm speaking i'm speaking
yeah and then we'll give the vice
president
so i want to ask the american people how
calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how come were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how come thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because you were afraid they could kill
them let's give vice president pence a
chance to respond vice presidents you
have one minute to receive you know
there's not a day gone by that i haven't
thought of every american family that's
lost the love
all right so when we're talking about
the corona thing it's very hard to parse
all this out because you need to be
sitting there with the exact calendar of
who said what
on what day and we do know that
the day on january 28th this is a
fact fact check me fact checkers
on january 28th when trump did the china
ban joe biden
said he either said he was xenophobic or
racist i think he said it was xenophobic
cnn actually fact checked him
and they said that it was partly true or
partly false
partly true partly false i suppose
that's the same thing because
he never directly said why trump was
being xenophobic but he happened to call
xeno
trump xenophobic that very day so look
we can get into all the who would have
done what
and there were debates i mean here's the
thing there were democratic debates
after january 28th
that nobody brought up coronavirus right
that nobody brought up kovid so the idea
that everyone was talking about this and
everyone knew this thing was gonna
happen there were some people
talking about it and there were little
whispers of it right um i you know i
love hearing people say all the time
obviously fox news tricked our viewers
into thinking this thing wasn't real
greg gutfeld was on the five talking
about it in late january
okay um that that is a fact
and there were other people doing the
same thing um so look
i i think the the better way to frame a
conversation about a corona
virus response is i think there's
certain there's a certain type of people
that we
think that we can build some sort of
perfect system and within that perfect
system nothing is going to get in
nothing is going to get out this
the government will somehow protect you
from all things
and and that it in and of itself can be
perfect and that when they get a warning
about everything that they automatically
will do
everything they can now of course the
irony of this is
kamala's implication there is oh trump
got the warning
in january and didn't do anything now if
he had gotten a warning in january and
started to do something
started to do a national lockdown or
something like that
what do you think they would have been
saying about trump about the man they
call hitler if
hitler started forcing a national
lockdown do you think
they might have said that's not good
hitler i'm pretty sure that's what they
would have said and
that's that's why the the hindsight on
this thing
and and this is where the playing teams
thing comes in
so so uh obviously it's like look if
obama was president and did the exact
same stuff as trump
the media would be telling you that
everything happening right now is a
right-wing conspiracy and it's those
crazy conservatives
who have caused all of the problems and
they didn't give the
power to the president to do the stuff
that he needed to do and that's why 200
000 people are dead
and that's what the media would be
cheering on it just it just is
so i don't think you can build a perfect
system and let me be very clear about
this i am not defending every decision
that trump made
and i don't think any i don't even think
anyone in his administration really
would defend
every single decision he made along the
way there is going to be mistakes and
this thing about
this thing about that he hid when he
knew that it was going to be bad that he
hid some information
first off he's actually been quite
honest about that that he has to be a
cheerleader for the country and he
didn't want
people to panic and all those things i
think there's a perfectly fine argument
within that you don't want you don't
want a president that is going to be
get some information and be like holy
[ __ ] we're all going to die
like you don't want that right so like
he was trying to like keep the wheels
on the car as we're potentially going
off a cliff right trying to make sure
that the brakes don't blow out
so i think there's something there but
this is one of those things it's like
if the democrats if obama did the same
exact thing
he would be a hero trump did it this way
he's evil
again i would throw most of this stuff
back to the states
and let them figure out what to do and
even right now
you know it's like we've got we've got
cuomo uh
in new york and he's shutting down
synagogues again
and uh and his ding dong brother in uh
on cnn who faked having well i don't
know if he faked having coveted but
he claimed he was in a basement for
weeks because of kovid and then was
caught outside his hamptons house
getting into a fight with a bicyclist
and then they staged
him coming out of his basement on cnn
with a sweat because he was you know
really
cold it makes you sweat um anyway the
media is
just terrible i'd rather have a debate
about the media could we just talk about
the media that was pence did have a nice
moment where he just really hit the
media because we just simply
can't trust these people the fact that
you people have to watch me
to pilfer out a little truth out of this
thing tells you something is deeply
deeply wrong
all right people i'm gonna take another
swig
we've got another debate in i think it's
about 10 days from now or
is it the 15th do you know the date off
the top of your head
next thursday so today's wednesday so
that's eight days we got a debate
in eight days we will be back live for
that i'll be back live tomorrow morning
at 11 a.m for the direct message we'll
probably have some debate follow-up and
and some other stuff i'm really digging
these direct messages and and clearly by
the numbers you guys are digging them
too so i appreciate that
uh i think there are good things
happening and by the way i want to just
i'll leave you with something something
positive for the end of the evening
we will get through this i know it feels
crazy i know it feels like your neighbor
hates you and your cousin hates you and
everyone's going bananas and a lot of
that's true to a certain degree
um but it's also partly just the media
it's partly just social media and how we
all behave on all those things
but i think we will get through this
there have been worse things that
america has been through right we've
been through civil wars we've been
through
a war of independence we've been in in
two world wars
um you know we've we've been to vietnam
we've had mass
civil rights movements we've done like a
lot of stuff has happened in the 250
incredible years of the united states
and we will get
through this slog what we're in right
now is the end of
one phase we're in the end of the baby
boomer phase of this thing
and there is a new world coming on the
other side and i think if you're a
responsible person with your head on
straight what your job is
is to say okay what was good out of that
world let's conserve that
and what is new in the new world that we
should be looking
to in the distance and that's also what
we should be going to and if we can
blend those two things correctly
we can have a a functional
decent free world that's full of
equality in the truest sense
and if i'm not mistaken there's a guy
who wrote a new york times best-selling
book
that came out last april that's writing
a book about the very thing that he was
just talking about on this very live
stream who could that possibly be
perhaps coming out in the spring of 2022
there's a little info for you
all right guys i got to go i'm on with
glenn beck and the blaze people
in about five minutes i'll see you there
thanks